and hello and welcome to this video
fernanda motta yes elegance defense why
not let's do something something else
okay have to be a bit cautious see I
couldn't be five might win a pawn so I'm
pretty seven yeah yeah yeah you want the
poor I understand you greedy little one
I don't give it to you look like that
and surprising and not to f3 has looked
a lot more normal age 5 f-5 is that the
idea probably okay let's get out of this
I'm happy that the nice on e to win or
an f3 that would have thin I mean it's
not it wouldn't have been the same
sequence of move afterwards but so it
doesn't feel that terrible sorry about
that switch the phone off which I quite
often do with I have record videos but
didn't do it now I got Bishop f6 that's
a bit of a shame the interesting idea to
just take on e5 I'll do that that that
that at least make sure that I'm not
getting into this bond with Bishop to
have six and so on and okay didn't see
that move
I sewed for Bishop f4 playing for tricks
mr. Martin oh shoot ah come on don't
tell me I'm lost here already against
his stuff this nightie 2g4 crap sorry
plane to plane too relaxed him
Queenie five Bishop f4 unfortunately
Quincy five has got to be should be
three
check ah I'm such an idiot
still kind of unclear this position and
this is not clear to me
okay so at least Bishop f4 is not coming
should have success possible
stepping out of Bishop f6 so I have a
couple of porns two points for the peace
rook be a to be to hike would be good if
I can get that in on trade that bloody
rook also be good and don't see how
rookie 7i think i can go King d6 it
shouldn't be so terrible 93 i think i
need to prevent okay so coming around
there
well he should win this position but
it's not not so easy to play I know for
sure that if I would be white yet had
have I would have plenty of ideas to
screw it up you probably win it totally
convincingly but it's not it's not that
easy
for look after I book takes f6 of course
this is a little threat time morning
remove the king it's got nite nite eggs
I shoot I don't have a good square and
he's threatening big them
I don't have a square for the quota King
god damn it
I can just take that I can just take
that
I yes be should be five check nice play
a very well what can you do I mean not
the start of the game but later check
okay at least is blundering something
check check check
eight seconds he has completely screwed
it up and check check
check check check stalemate jack all
rights total denial for its fine haha
that's it come that dance ah the
tiebreaking it's heartbreaking Jack
really hate stuff like that they do
everything to screw it up everything yet
to a total drawn position then they've
been on time okay yeah and okay I mean I
don't believe any of that here maybe I
should just go age 51 97 awesome yeah
this is the thing I just 26 it's just
bad I should just spend like a just a
moment to see that that this Bishop f4
is working this is what I have to do
this is the interesting position I
really don't know what to make of it
okay the engine gives it gives it as a
draw direct repetition yeah i think what
maybe needs to do that playing on this
is bad playing on is bad
yeah wonder if i can i can do something
about this because
I probably gets it in I mean things I
just have to make sure that f5 f5 is
never never coming this position is
strategically terrible for Whitey's got
the dead bishop there and complete wreck
of a porn structure so he has to get
that in but it seems he gets it in maybe
I should start with those moves cm ok
can't start g4 immediately he always has
this this is important I can do this I
mean maybe this is an idea and this kind
of thing and I doubt that this is
working now it should be ok because the
way it went it was more of AI like an
emergency exit that that sacrifice when
the engine just wants to do this but I
don't understand after this I'm are not
just bit worse ok I can take and this is
ok and Luke cheeks and wants to go g5
and then aged five actually be in bad
shape but yeah I played this this very
well oops I can take you five I was
thinking that would work I know the
check oh I didn't think about that one
ah i just made a terrible calculation
mistake so we actually played it bad
check
Bishop f4 cannot be played so he has to
move the Queen and okay yeah I'm just in
great shape great shape I don't know
yeah but I am but I'm somewhat better at
least huh check very bad yeah now I know
I'm losing do I felt it there were a
couple of it was kind of interesting but
did that part of the game we played very
well I believe all those moosian and
Bishop h5 event and so on it was all
very strong check yeah also that just
taking here going back check I have
nowhere and check and chani way out of
this only he started to screw it up
completely I mean okay he knows that he
will be known time very likely but it
was absolutely close I mean I just had
to get get rid of that that last porn
just too technically make it a draw it
is so it is a draw of course I just by
position and this would be very quickly
now actually yeah I have one second one
second this would be really clear I've
get the check and get the porn so I will
get the point in two of two or three
moves but it wasn't wasn't possible to
do okay thanks for watching